everybody and welcome to part five of
our game development in Python with
Python 3 and PI game where we left off
we added some boundaries for a car and
right now if we crash we just say game
exits that's not really good because the
user might want to play again and again
and again and so what we want to have is
something very specific for when the car
crashes as opposed to when the person
wants to exit the game now to do that
what we're going to do is if the user
crashes we want to display some text to
the screen and then we want to allow
them to just play again so the game
should reset somehow so that's what
we're going to do next so um so we'll
take and get a phone call
anyway uh we'll take what we have now
and then basically what we want to
happen what I like to do when I program
is just kind of like program in Reverse
sometimes so we have an end goal in mind
and then we program in reverse to reach
that end goal so our end goal is
actually very complex so we have this
end goal of you know we want some sort
of way to display like you crashed on
the screen and and in some way to maybe
restart or you know send them a message
and then have them restored so we want
some sort of messaging ability and this
is I there's a lot of code involved in
that but at the end of the day what do
we want to do well the other day what
we'd like to do is if you know if this
is the case then we want to say crash we
just want to say crash crash function
run yeah that's what we want so we don't
have a crash function so now we have to
define our crash function so we'll come
up here to our list of functions which
right now is really just one besides
your game loop but you'll see as time
goes on you'll add many many functions
so we've got car now we need a new
function crash so define crash empty
parameters and what do we want this
crash function to do well when the user
crashes you might you might
I have some sort of display of the
wheels flying off or something like that
but for now we just want to keep it
simple if we crash we want a message
underscore display well I like send a
message to this place where we want to
run a function that messages to the
display um you crashed okay that's what
we want to do so we'll run you crashed
like that and everybody will be happy so
now we see okay so we want the crash
function to run a message to display now
why don't we just have crash doing what
the message display function would do
well there might be other reasons why
you want to message the display screen
there might be other reasons besides
just a user crashing you might want to
have other messages play like good job
or you beat your record or whatever um
so we don't necessarily want to have
this whole message display function
built in a crash but anyway so crash
that's all we want to do we want to run
this you crashed basically message so
now we have to define message display
this one's a little more complex so
define message underscore display and we
know that we want to have one parameter
that we pass through it so what is that
parameter we're just gonna say text so
what is the text that we want to display
and that's what this function is going
to do so the display text that we're
going to run our call is going to be
text equals actually the price should
not redefine text we'll say
we'll call this large text and large
text equals PI game dot font dot capital
F fine and then you can specify the font
type and the font size our font type
we're going to use free sans bold TTFN
and the font size for this large text
you don't really know until you see it
but you know this text on my screen
right here is size 22 so we'd want a
little bit bigger than that for sure so
we're going to say um 115 so we'll make
that text font size 115 now what do we
want we've got the text so we've got the
text in mind the size and the text know
so you could select a font let's say
you're in a word editor and you select a
font in size well nothing's there yet
right so you have to you know write it
out basically and the way that it works
in pygame
is you can write it out and then where
you've written it out it's almost like
if you were in paint or something and
you you say you want to add text and it
makes like a square right around the
text and you can move the text around
it's the same thing here so you'll write
some text but that text is going to be
referenced by the rectangle that in
cases that text so we can use that to
place the text and you'll see what I
mean in a minute so now we're going to
say um text surface or text surf and
then text rect so the surface and then
the rectangle that contains it is going
to equal mmm text underscore objects and
then in here we pass through text and
then a large text like that so that's
that so though that what that's going to
do is return to us the text surface and
the text rectangle the next thing that
we're going to do is going to be well
first of all we're going to have to
define text objects those objects
doesn't exist
so we're gonna have to backtrack on that
one as well but this is what how we want
this to work so equals that and now what
we're going to do is basically we want
to have this message be kind of like
centered on the screen so to do that
we're going to say um text rect
dot Center equals and this is going to
be um display width so up here we've
defined display width as 800 so we're
going on this text how would we Center
it well we would Center it in the middle
of display width in the middle of
display height so display width divided
by two and so that's the X basically
where we want the X and then the Y is
going to be display and let me make some
space here display underscore height and
then this will also be divided by two so
that's this how to Center it now what
we're going to say is we're gonna say
game display dot lit so remember we use
blit with our image to kind of like draw
it to the screen it's not yet showing it
but it's like they're in the background
so game display blit and what do we want
to actually blit is the text surface and
then text rectangle and and that's it
basically for our message display and
then for our message display um we
really just want that to be on the
screen for X amount of moments so what
we can do is we could basically say
message display and then time dot sleep
two seconds or something like that and
we can make the game start over and then
after those two seconds are done how
would we start the game
/ well if we don't do anything when this
is all done it would go pike and quit
and then quit it would leave the game we
don't really want that to happen so
after we've slept
we'll just rear efference game loop and
that will start everything over again
I'll start the car over start the X
changeover it'll start gaem exit over
and it starts all of our logic over our
score which will have later on objects
and difficulty everything will just be
reset right so let's save this actually
we can't we can't do anything just yet
because we we solve one more function
that we haven't described yet and that's
text objects so now we have to define
text objects so come over here and we'll
say define text underscore objects and
we know that we want to pass two
functions through and that's going to be
text and then what is the text basically
so so text and then font basically so
large text is what is the font and the
size so we want to pass through it um
text and font okay of our text objects
now this one's pretty simple text
objects will just be text surface equals
font dot render and luckily font dot
render is something that is included
with my game so we don't have to code
that find out a render what do we want
to render we want to render the text the
next parameters for anti-aliasing for
now we're just going to not consider
what that is and all that we're just
going to use true and then what color do
we want that font to be for now we have
black and white since our background is
white we should use black we could also
do red though and then later on as well
you could pass you could say color here
and we could really customize a lot of
messaging and you could pass whatever
color you want it so if you crash that's
red if you did really good green you
know that kind of stuff so here we
render the font and then at the end of
it we return text surface and then text
surface dot get underscore rectangle so
if you remember
the reason why we're doing that is so so
that we can get the rectangle of you
know around our text so we can use that
to position our text which we do right
here and that's it that should run um
should display our message for two
seconds and then return the game live
let's see how that works out to us so
here's a car awesome and we crash oh oh
oh we have not imported time yes all the
way to the top where you have import pie
game we will import time let's try that
again
what about sound so we crash and we
didn't get the message this surface
whoops oh and probably the reason why we
didn't is here we game displayed up lit
but we didn't update the display so we
need to do game display dot update um I
want to say we need one more thing yeah
game PI game dot display to update
that's what it is
copy come back up here paste so we need
to after we've right this because this
is basically in the background so then
you have to update it to your display so
let's try that so you can get by this
way there we go
okay so we've got our message you
crashed holds there for two seconds
and the game starts again let's try the
other side now let me crashed game over
you start again okay so then we have a
very basic messaging system oh and
here's why ah nice so this needs a run a
quit so when you hit the X it's we're
still running that crashed right it's
running the crash and professionally
ever leaving so we'll come over here and
game x equals true we don't really want
that to be the case so if if the person
wants to quit basically we can just run
these two things PI game dot quit and
then quit so we could go here and we go
Oh pygame quit and then we call to quit
for Python so let's save and run that
one more time
and crash we still crash cool we still
play but then when we hit the X we leave
ok that's what we want
awesome ok so now we've got some
boundaries um we've got this kind of
like you crashed functionality going on
now we're ready to kind of add a the
actual point of the game which would be
like objects and stuff that we're ready
to avoid and that kind of stuff so
anyway stay tuned for that if you guys
have any questions or comments something
going wrong here
feel free to leave those questions
comments below as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the support
subscriptions until next time